foreign
to the minimalist podcast where we
discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
Joshua Fields Milburn and I'm Ryan
Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists we're here in the studio
with malabama hi everybody and guess
who's back TK Coleman what it is welcome
back we got the rest of our team here in
the studio as well and coming up today
on this free public minimal episode
we're talking to a couple of listeners
about perfectionism we're joined by a
guest expert we'll introduce her in a
moment we also have an outstanding
lightning round segment a live stream
question and a listener tip for you you
can check out the full two hour maximal
edition of episode 381 where we answer
four times the questions and we dive
deep into several simple living segments
that private podcast episode is out
right now at patreon.com the minimalists
your support keeps our podcast and
YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free because
say it with me y'all
advertisements suck our first question
today is from YouTube symbaline asks my
perfectionism gets in the way of my
projects at work even with 20 years of
experience and a PhD I agonize delay and
self-sabotage I'm perfectly qualified to
do my job so why is it so hard for me to
sit down and do the work
well we're joined in the studio today by
Katherine Morgan schaffler she's the
author of this new book if you're
watching the video version of the
podcast it is called the perfectionist
guide to losing control now Catherine
before we answer this question directly
I want to say I first misread the title
and this is my own
imperfections my own perfectionism I
read it as the perfectionist guide to
losing everything
but isn't it a Freudian slip sort of
because to a perfectionist control is
all that I have and I need more of it
and I would be satisfied if only I could
get more control if I had more dominion
over my domain I would be happier I'd be
more complete it's like psychological
consumerism in a way I'm going to
complete myself if I just had more
control and of course what happens I get
some control and I just need more it
becomes this unquenchable thirst yeah
yeah I mean that's how you get stuck in
the game because there's intermittent
reward when you think about how you
cannot control so much and I would say
most things in life you can control some
stuff some of the time and when you
control something and manipulate in such
a way that you get the outcome you want
it's like
and then you want to play more and get
to the next level and do all this stuff
and of course
to your point it's all an illusion and
the subtitle of the book a path to peace
and power is about control is just this
generic cardboard cutout version of
power yes we don't actually want control
what we want is power and power is
always the upgrade it's always available
to everybody it's coming from within
yourself it doesn't need to be
externally sourced whereas control is
like the opposite in so many ways but
it's like lust and love they look so
similar and it's really hard to tell the
difference wait please tell I gotta hear
her definition of power like what is
power power is understanding the
immutability of your worth that's how I
Define power people who are powerful
know that there is not one thing
that you can do or not do that would
change the fact that all the time even
when you're sleeping even when you are
completely messing up whatever you're
trying to do you are still worthy of all
the love joy connection freedom and
dignity that like if you imagine the
most accomplished
ideal version of yourself that person
and you right now are equally worthy of
those things perfectionism
or Perfection is maybe a better way to
look at this is sort of the default
state of the universe and we try to
attain it thinking that I can become
more perfect yeah but that's even in the
founding documents of this country like
a more perfect union as though I can
become perfect and then I can then make
it more perfect but Perfection isn't
attained it is uncovered in a way by
understanding the acceptance thing you
were talking about now Catherine you're
a psychotherapist and in the book you
talk about the five types of
perfectionists and I thought this was
ideal to answer a symbolines question
here because she is a perfectionist at
work and she says even I have 20 years
of experience I have a PhD but I still
agonize every day I delay I
self-sabotage what type of perfectionist
is this okay well here's the thing just
to lay
the lay of the land is that
something that bothers me and has always
bothered me about addressing
perfectionism and perfectionists is that
the general
message in the self-help slash personal
development world is like just don't be
a perfectionist just be less of a
perfectionist yeah just like don't sweat
the small stuff and lower your standards
a little bit and that doesn't work it's
like telling someone who's really pissed
off to calm down it makes works every
time
I am calm
relax oh shoot right and it not only
doesn't work but it actually makes
Perfections feel really isolated because
it's immediately like oh you don't get
it I can't just shut this off right so
this question the thing I'm hearing
before I hear anything else it's like I
can't turn this off I haven't been able
to turn this off for 20 years probably
before 20 years and so this book is
about completely flipping the way that
we think about perfectionism and
perfectionists and first understanding
that if you're a perfectionist that's an
that's a big core part of your identity
it's like being a romantic or being an
activist it's not something you can
necessarily edit out of yourself and so
the book takes an integration approach
instead of the eradication approach
which is like just don't be a
perfectionist
um in the same way that Romantics can
have a lot of problems if they don't
have boundaries around the way they love
or their impulsivity or whatever else is
going on that doesn't mean that being a
romantic is unhealthy it just means you
need to be really self-aware understand
your triggers
like recognize some patterns how you
want to switch them up the patterns that
you want to keep and maintain and
perfectionism I see as the same thing
it's not a bad thing you don't have to
stop being a perfectionist to be healthy
you just have to understand where it can
help you and where it can hurt you
because it's a very powerful force
perfectionism it's a force I think is
present in everybody
but perfectionists are people who feel
that impulse to actively chase the idea
more often than not they feel it in a
really reliable consistent patterned way
and so you know long story short
it's not perfectionism that is your
problem it's how you respond to it and
it sounds like this caller is responding
to it with a lot of punishment and
punishment is not powerful it is
terrible toxic there's no healthy
version of it punishment will just take
you down it's funny how punishment
sometimes like it makes us feel better
about our imperfections well at least I
feel guilty about it and I'm punishing
myself yeah but I love how you're um
you're relieving people of the guilt of
being a perfectionist yeah and you know
to your point Josh it's that the first
person to bring up perfectionism in
psychological literature with this guy
Dr Alfred Adler who everybody knows
because this is the guy who coined the
term inferiority complex and he was a
socialist and his ideas didn't get a lot
of traction for a lot of reasons but
mostly because they didn't fit into the
mold at the time which was way back in
the day like Freud day like 1910s and he
said
that perfectionism is the Eternal Melody
we all hear and because he believed
people are good inside and so if you
leave people to their own devices that's
driving and pushing towards the ideal
that perfectionists actively feel
um is because we all want to be more
connected and Adler saw all neuroses as
an absence of connection and he said if
everybody was clean clothed safe fed and
free there would be no perfectionism
because we would have the idea already
but because there's not perfectionism is
always going to be here and that's where
the whole inferiority complex comes in
like we know at all times we're not as
connected we're not taking care of each
other we're not and we feel that and
there's been a compensatory drive to fix
that and if that compensatory drive is
kind of more reactive than responsive it
ends up being unhealthy because you try
to get like the Quick Fix yeah and so
that's when perfect maladaptive
perfectionism is is the research term
for unhealthy perfectionism and adaptive
perfectionism is when you use
perfectionism to help you and hurt to
help you and heal you it sounds to me
like what Adler was saying is sort of
the opposite of what Dostoyevsky talks
about when he says like if the thing is
from notes in the underground uh he's
talking about how if everyone got
everything that they wanted they became
perfect they would find a way to
sabotage that in order to create an
imperfection because we're all it's
almost as though we are these
problem-solving creatures and I think
there's something about perfectionism
that says I need something to fix I'm
going around with a solution in search
of a problem yeah well you're touching
on that human aspect of it and something
that surprised me when I was researching
for this book and thinking about my
clients is that perfectionism is
compulsive like this person who cannot
stop doing it it is compulsive and
compulsivity is often a marker for
dysfunction if you can't control it then
something's wrong but then I started
thinking about other stuff that's
compulsive like the need to tell stories
or or to touch or kiss or talk even and
that it's actually not a sign of Health
if we just sit here and are like
templates of what a human being is
supposed to be and we never
kind of let the I guess it's a little
bit of what I would call activation
anxiety to like touch the thing or talk
to the person or you know it's like
sitting in this quiet quote-unquote
meditative State all the time
that's a little bit overrated frankly
um
yeah so let me ask you someone who has
like an unhealthy level of perfectionism
in their life yeah would you like
recommend for them to like I don't know
first look at kind of the connection
that they have in their lives is that a
good place to start yeah I mean a really
good place to start is understanding
that
all people who consider themselves
perfectionists are both healthy and
unhealthy perfectionists so we talk
about health and mental health in
particular as this kind of like flag
that you can catch and then plant and
you're like I'm healthy now and that is
not how it works and mental health is so
much more fluid and so much more context
dependent than we think of it as and the
reason that we think of it that way is
because
mental health right now is organized in
these categorical models of like I'm
depressed or I'm not depressed I'm you
know suffering from bipolar disorder I'm
not and everything actually operates on
a Continuum and we're all like sometimes
a little bit of a narcissist or a little
bit depressed-ish I'm like I like a lot
of gray language and mental health but
that doesn't help when you need the
label to help you understand like this
is gonna show up in this way in your
life
um and here's how to understand it and
plan for it and kind of manage it and in
that way labels are healthy but in
another way they're not because when
someone is in like a healthy space I
think they feel like well nothing can
happened to me now or I'm not at risk of
like slipping because
I'm doing all the healthy stuff you know
yeah
yeah labels are a good
um I don't know guide but I think it can
be detrimental to use those labels to
Define who we are as a person 100 and
and to get to your question the two
things you want to see if you really
want to test where your perfectionism is
at in terms of whether it's in a healthy
or unhealthy space it's like how are you
striving and why are you striving and so
if the how is like you're striving in a
way that feels good and energizing and
connective for you then that's adaptive
perfectionism if you're striving in a
way where you're just burning yourself
out and you're you're frustrating
yourself and pissing yourself off and
all that stuff that's more maladaptive
and the why are you striving is like are
you striving because you think you're
gonna get this thing x amount of
listeners x amount of money x amount on
number on the scale and that's going to
certify your belonging somewhere to some
club or some group or that's going to
make you feel worthy of all the stuff we
talked about at the top of the
conversation
or are you are you striving because
you love to and it makes you feel like
more of who you are and you're not so
attached to the outcome you're obsessed
with the process and if you're striving
for those reasons then that's healthy
perfectionism yeah it's almost like we
we're abutting the limitations of the
English language here right because what
we're talking about is like striving
versus you know someone might call that
a Chase someone else might call it
Devotion to something right yeah and
it's the the devotion side I see as
being the sort of healthy Obsession
about something the striving for a
particular outcome we're chasing an
outcome is a Surefire path to misery
because what happens is you get it and
then you're happy for about three
seconds and then oh wow look at me we're
just talking about this this morning now
when we were talking about pride and how
Harold loadskin talks about how pride is
essentially the fear of not being able
to do something again which I thought
was a really interesting framing because
here's the thing like if I we were
nominated for an Emmy a few years ago
and it'd be easy to feel Pride for that
at first but then what's the pride
saying oh oh this is rare I might not be
able to do this again or the very first
time I tied my shoe I felt Pride around
that was a late shoe Tire I didn't get
to it I was like seven or eight years
old and uh so I felt a lot of Pride but
imagine if I walked into this studio
today and I was like you're not gonna
believe this Catherine I was able to tie
my shoe all by myself this morning
well I don't feel that way because
there's no scarcity around there's no
fear that I won't be able to do that
again I do want to touch on the five
types of perfectionists in a moment but
let's tune in to Instagram malabama we
got a question from Rose I'm
cohabitating with someone who isn't a
minimalist and I need help on developing
some strategies to maintain our common
spaces I know it isn't reasonable to
hold them to my high standards but I
don't want to play made to them either
we've tried several different systems to
keep clutter at Bay but it never seems
to last for long what are some tools to
help me keep the peace and keep things
organized so Catherine I'm interested in
this question because I I do suffer from
perfectionism to the point where it
becomes the opposite of productive it
becomes neurotic I narose over it and it
becomes a type of prison in your book
what you talk about is having boundaries
around the perfectionism because
I think we were talking about this
earlier to some extent but the Chase
isn't going to bring happiness and so I
think the same thing is true with
decluttering decluttering is not going
to bring you peace it's going to set up
the environment in which you've removed
the chaos and so you can be peaceful but
let's be frank about this it's also
possible to be at peace within a room a
warehouse full of clutter right even
right and so
psychologically what is going on here
when you're cohabitating with someone
and of course all of my state this is a
George Carlin bit basically like all of
my stuff is stuff and all your stuff is
crap and and what we're doing is simply
projecting our own image of the world
onto someone else you should be this way
you should behave this way and you
should pacify me you should think the
same way that I do and no wonder uh Rose
feels miserable right now because it's
heaping those expectations onto someone
else and by the way I totally get it the
I have compassion for Rose because this
question it resonates with me I have a
family a wife and a daughter and our
house will be far more spartanist if it
was up to me yeah uh we solve a
relatively minimalist home as you can
see from the we do minimalist home tours
over on patreon and
yet it's still not exactly the way I
would like it to be it's not perfect
yeah I mean it's I'm laughing because
it's such a universal struggle of and
particularly in this example of living
with somebody and you know we're so
often drawn towards people who have the
opposite attracts thing and so if you
are a minimalist it is interesting then
I think a lot of people are drawn to
someone who is the opposite in some way
and I think really
breaking that down into two parts one is
if you can explain the undercurrent of
your preferences and your
perfectionistic Tendencies to someone
that's going to get you a lot more
mileage than saying I really need the
kitchen counter to be clear okay just
clear it you know I want it to be clear
why do you leave this junk here every
night if you can say when the kitchen
counter is clear
my mind is more clear I remember more
stuff about what I value and I have it's
like you know taking a walk for me and
when you put stuff on the kitchen
counter it takes that stuff away from me
or when you you know leave your clothes
all over the floor it's like you're
interrupting me so if you can kind of
not make it about there's an old adage
in therapy of it's never about what it's
about right it's not about the stuff in
the house it's about your access to your
own feelings and your sense that your
partner
doesn't care about that and if you can
address that then you're probably going
to see a little more motivation on the
side of your partner to be like oh I
don't want to interrupt her let me clear
this away and then the second thing is
and I talk about these six different
types of support to help you understand
like which bucket you need to pick up
and pour over your life because
sometimes it's like I need so much help
I know I'm so stressed I'm overwhelmed
and just giving yourself the language of
like look it's not that you need so much
help it's that you need financial
support right now you know what to do
you know how to do it you've got a team
around you you just need funds and in
this case this might be a tangible
support thing which is like having a
house cleaner every week or something
like that which people sometimes don't
give themselves because they
underestimate how powerful that can be
and it's also if you and your partner
are paying for a house cleaner and
investing then you're less likely to
keep
you know it's more of an intentional
mission of like this house want needs to
be this way for a reason and so I would
say those two things are good starting
points to the convo and sometimes acting
on starting points like that like
getting someone to help with the
cleaning we we have this inner
resistance that says oh but that would
be pathetic of me to bring someone from
the outside to do what I am perfectly
able to do and it's letting that
expectation of ourselves go and saying
no it's never pathetic of me to get the
help that I need right yeah yeah you
know I used to live in LA and when I
lived here I really had it in my head
that if it was in my early 20s that if I
asked for help for it for anything from
anybody I like whatever I achieved
didn't count I was cheating I was
cheating so don't ask for help because
then it doesn't even count if you get it
it's not even a feel good and I remember
I went through this abrupt breakup when
I was 24.
and the guy who's dating was such a
great guy and like we were both sharing
the rent and he would have been very
happy to like stay on the couch for a
while or whatever but I was like I'm
gonna be out of this house tonight with
me and my dog I looked on Craigslist for
the first available apartment
that night and I just moved all my stuff
into this apartment that was I tell this
story in the book owned by this guy
named Dax okay and Dax I want everybody
to know I had a license plate that's a
Dax to see
this is like red flags waving billowing
in the air and I did not care because I
was like I'm doing this by myself I
could have asked 50 billion friends to
just crash at their place for a little
while whatever it was and then I lived
there for a month and it was like I'm
laughing about it now but Dax and his
friend who also lived there were so
sketchy and like
did a lot of drugs and drank a lot of
alcohol and like partied all night long
and I just felt so much pride to your
point of like I'm doing it by myself
even though I feel unsafe even though I
feel like this is not a good choice but
I'm I'm not asking for help and it took
me so long to just get to this place
where it's like not only
is asking for help always the move it's
like this the smartest and strongest
people are the ones who ask for help if
you look at successful people they have
personal assistance they have this they
have that like they've streamlined their
life so that they have as much help in
as many areas as possible so it's a hard
thing to take in but once you take it in
it just allows you to have so much more
access to yourself and this comes back
to back to your point about worthiness
right it's I am worthy of this even if I
haven't suffered for it yeah the
suffering is such a big one because it's
like I suffered I'm miserable see how
responsible I am
I'm worthy because I'm suffering right I
want to Circle back to one thing real
quick you you mentioned the the house
cleaner I have a separate problem my
perfection is I'm very obsessive OCD and
and um
to a certain extent it becomes a
superpower and you write about this in
the book it I that rigidness that
structure has allowed me to create
things that I don't think I could have
created otherwise the problem is when it
becomes too rigid and sometimes it's
like when there are too many boundaries
that is a type of non-boundary in a way
because it it restricts your freedom
and the opposite is also true With No
Boundaries you have no Freedom yeah
because you don't have a place in which
to operate you don't know what the rules
are to your own life I noticed um when I
hired a house cleaner once they came
over and she did an awesome awesome job
in fact she used to clean the studio
here floor and when she came to my house
and really she was just a disorganizing
consultant
because like my shelves look like
they're like you go to the laundry
cabinet and like everything is lined up
like a retail store would be every every
label is facing outward and and she just
came over and I swear she came in and
just did this right she would just like
turn the label just slightly and set it
back down and so I'll move the Windex in
front of the counter cleaner and it's
like no what are you doing
this feels so out of control yeah but
the truth is there's no
that's merely a story I'm telling myself
and I wanted to Circle back because in
the book you talk about the five types
of perfectionists which which type am I
so that would be a classic perfectionist
so classic perfectionists are what we
most think of when we think of the
perfectionist someone who
might be a little rigid sometimes and
likes their stuff the way they like
their stuff and they're highly reliable
people so all kind all these types of
perfectionism
um have their advantages and have their
liabilities and classic perfectionists
on the Pro's side are so structured they
do what they say they're going to do
when they say they're going to do it in
the way they said they would do it right
and so they're very disciplined in that
way on the con side sometimes their
style of perfectionism doesn't lend
itself to
accepting help because it's like well if
I'm the the classic perfectionist line
in their heads it's like if you want
something done well do it yourself yes
and then it's like but you can't do all
the things yourself so subtitle to my
Memoir
put the Windex back
um so there's a classic perfectionist
right there's the procrastinator
perfectionist and this perfectionist
essentially
wants the conditions to be perfect
before they start
um which never happens and so on the pro
side these are really thoughtful people
these are people who can prepare they
are not impulsive which is such a
strength
um and they can see everything from a
360 degree angle but on the con side
obviously this kind of perfectionism
turns into paralysis and indecision and
a lot of self-loathing because you're
like why can't I just start the books do
this do that and the counterpart to the
procrastinated perfectionist is the
messy perfectionist and these are people
who are in love with starting they are
obsessed with starting they don't want
to do anything but start projects right
they're just like cast this huge net I'm
gonna have this podcast and write this
book and also be an Airbnb super host
and also do this and that whatever and
they really hit a wall when the middle
of the process like when the Perfection
and romanticized part of starting
something starts to break down so these
are people who love like the first
second date and then on the third date
they hear a little there's a little bit
of a glitch
and they're like oh I'm out I'm done you
know if you're not managing that kind of
perfectionism
um and then there is the Parisian
perfectionist and this perfectionism is
really interesting because it plays out
interpersonally so this is about wanting
people to perfectly like you perfectly
understand you and also wanting to
perfectly like other people and so the
ideal that's being chased here is ideal
connection and these people also want to
perfectly understand themselves or their
God whatever it is so a Parisian
perfectionist could be at like a regular
nine to five no upward Mobility you're
not seeing their perfectionism expressed
professionally necessarily or in like
classic perfectionist organizational
ways it all comes through
interpersonally and then there's the
intense perfectionist and this is like
what we think of the public Persona of
Gordon Ramsay or Steve Jobs and intense
perfectionists are really razor sharp
focus on the outcome the ending of a
process being perfect
and that's a great Advantage they're
effortlessly direct you know they're not
trying to do anything but get the job
done and if you're not managing that
perfectionism you can get to the goal
and just leave like a
a trail of Devastation and it's like
great you got the thing every you got
the goal everybody's gonna quit next
month because they're all miserable you
know this is like great Christmas and
everything is decorated perfectly and
everybody's here and and dinner is hot
and on time and like do you see how
disconnected everybody is at the table
like yeah you know and so all these
kinds of perfectionisms can play out in
positive ways negative ways and a lot in
between
Ryan what time is it you know what time
it is it's time for the lightning round
where we answer your questions from Tick
Tock yes indeed you can follow the
minimalist on Tick Tock Instagram
Facebook and Twitter at the minimalist
during the lightning round we each have
60 seconds to answer your questions with
a short shareable less than 140
character response we call the minimal
maxims and we put these minimal maxims
in the show notes over at podcasts oh
the minimalists.com podcast so you can
copy and share our pithy answers on
social media if you'd like looks like
our question today is from Dr Wright if
you guys don't run ads how do you make
money
what an interesting question because
there's so many things that this
question presupposes and since Ryan and
I have similar minimal maxims I didn't
share mine with him beforehand I'll let
him start today thanks let's give him 60
seconds Professor Sean
all right am I going oh I'm already one
second into it all right here we go
when you add value
people are eager to support your work
so often family members friends
listeners they're like hey I wanna I
Wanna Be an entrepreneur I want to do
what you do tell me how can I make a
living from from my passion and my
response is never like well here's the
10 best ways to make money from your
passion what what I what I tell them is
hey look if you're really passionate
about something then go ahead and do it
and what happens is when you fulfill
that passion and work comes out of it
and it's adding value to other people's
lives those people are going to go way
out of their way to support you to make
sure that you can still continue
producing your work and there is no one
specific way there are many ways to make
money from your passion in the ways that
Josh and I make money is very different
than how TK makes his money and so on
and so forth so follow cultivate your
passion yeah yeah you know what's fast
about what you're saying here is there
will be people who support your work
right but not all everyone will and I
think that's where we really get caught
up is we think that like oh I have to do
something where everyone will support me
but then it goes back to the idea of the
Kevin Kelly thousand true fans thing
like you only need a thousand true fans
or some artists need 12 true fans and
they will have uh a very abundant
wealthy life with those 12 true fans or
100 True fans or thousand true fans but
TK this question let's give you 60
seconds here in a moment but this
question it almost presupposes that like
it's binary either you're not going to
make money
or you are going to make money but you
have to do advertisements and of course
on the private podcast we have every
week we have the advertisement suck
segment in fact I'm calling someone out
this week specifically and so we'll get
into that but this presupposing that you
must do something also limits our
creativity in a way Professor Sean let's
give TK Coleman 60 seconds on the clock
so I can ignore it anyway
you're three seconds in TK for most of
human history people earned money
without a single advertisement now I
don't mean that people made money
without getting the word out there
that's a part of making a living right
you spread the word about the problems
you can solve about the services you can
provide and so on what I'm talking about
here are those artifacts those artifacts
that fill up these empty vacuums these
territories that we call at space right
like the billboard can I put a sticker
on your T-shirt can I put something on
your car can I put this Banner on your
video can I interrupt your movie with
the commercial ad space those
advertisements yeah people make money
with that it's a legitimate way to make
money but for most of human history
people simply made money by creating
value satisfying the hell out of their
customers taking care of people so well
that they went out and told other people
about how awesome this service was and
that's what we do with a number of
things that we do we don't make our
money by saying you can buy our bodies
in exchange for a paycheck that's
beautiful I'll say this we are also not
allergic to money and so when we say
advertisements suck we're not saying
well I hate money I think money is evil
and bad and and immoral what I'm saying
is I have a preference here and it's
funny this question doesn't get asked of
like Radiohead no one goes up to Tom
York and says hey if you don't put your
music in commercials how do you make any
money right right because the music that
he makes in his band makes is not about
money right the music is a creative act
and if it adds value as Ryan said then
people are willing to support it and if
it doesn't add value then people aren't
going to support it so give me 60
seconds I'm just gonna Riff on what Ryan
said here
money is a byproduct of adding value
quite often we go the other way around
I'm going to find a way to make money
and then hope that it adds value but
there is no money being earned without
adding value yes you can steal money
from someone you can run into a bank and
take their money you can scam someone
and not add value and get their money
but if you want to earn a living if you
want to earn an income well you're going
to have to earn it by adding value and
so the question I have is who are you
adding value to are you going to add
value to the advertisers or are you
adding value to your audience because if
you're adding value to the advertisers
now all of a sudden your audience
is the product and that is the reason we
don't do advertisements on the
minimalist podcast
wow I love by the way you emphasizing
earning because every time I have ever
stated
the economic observation that money is a
reward for creating value I have people
who inform me that criminals exist and
that there are some people who make
money without adding value and so I love
the way you language that
um to just sort of circumvent that
objection and make that part clear TK
was writing it down he's like okay
robbing a bank yes scamming what else
was there
we're gonna check in with the patreon
live stream here in a moment but first
real quick for right here right now
here's one thing that's going on in the
life of the minimalists Ryan and I and
for about a third of them TK we went on
a tour last year was called the love
people use things tour there were 20
different events all of them were
recorded thanks to our good friend
Jordan no more over there and Danny
Danny came along to I think three of the
events the three best events that's
right we try to pit them against each
other is it working uh no they uh they
did an outstanding job uh podcast Sean
was with us as well we did 20 different
cities uh throughout North America and
you can find all 20 events right now the
minimalists.com previous we don't have
any intention on going on tour anytime
soon that was our 10th tour in 12 years
you can find all of the recordings there
the minimalists.com previous that'll
take you you to the patreon page then
you can watch each of those speaking of
Live Events though it looks like there
are fewer than I think 25 tickets right
now for the next Sunday Symposium which
is March 26 Sunday at noon if you're in
LA or if you want to come to La we had
quite a few people we had someone from
Germany at the last one a few people
from Mexico at least one person from
Canada and my favorite foreign country
someone came from Texas
it's funny because they're different
that Texan was actually Danny so any
unknown here standing over there like a
a sentinel watching guard over the
podcast and over our tick tocks you can
see us uh will be March 26th Sunday
Symposium in Los Angeles downtown LA
Sunday
symposium.com only a few tickets left to
that yeah let's check in with the
patreon live stream Alabama what do you
got for us we have a question here from
David he says is there a difference
between procrastination and resistance
I've seen this mentioned in Stephen
pressfield's the war of Art and notice a
lot of people talking about them like
they're the same thing I think quite
often those two words are used
interchangeably I will say this
resistance is a beacon that illuminates
meaningful Pursuits
so every morning this morning at 4am I
got into the ice bath and there's
resistance before I got in and by the
way I feel this resistance every single
time but I know that I'm going to be
pleased with myself that I'm going to be
glad after that experience at the end of
it right but also with procrastination I
think the opposite happens I don't know
if I'm going to
be appreciative of this outcome I don't
know if this is the thing I want to do
resistance says every morning when I sit
down to write ah there's something that
would be way easier than this scrolling
Instagram and double tapping again and
again and again is much easier than
sitting down and writing but it's not a
meaningful Pursuit for me it's not going
to give me the actual reward it'll give
me a little bit of dopamine but the
reward will not be there at the end of
it and I think that's the difference
between resistance and and
procrastination
yeah I see procrastination as one of
many manifestations of resistance I see
resistance is just like anything that
directs my focus away from being
committed to what I love to what brings
me joy and so resistance can take the
form of just flat out quitting flat out
giving up you know giving in to the fear
it can take many different forms
whatever it takes that's how Stephen
pressfield describes it whatever it
takes to get you to not move in the
direction of your life's calling that's
resistance it'll tell you whatever it
takes whereas procrastination is kind of
like this sense that if I put it off if
I don't do it now
maybe the future will bring me a moment
where it just feels easier it feels
easier to confront my fears and face the
risk and that's a very
interesting and unique particular form
of of resistance but resistance is
broader than that but procrastination is
one form yeah
and dig it we'll check back in with the
patreon live stream later in the private
podcast but first to Alabama what else
you got for us here's a minimalist
Insight from one of our listeners
hi my name is Catherine I currently live
in the Bay Area every
first week of December with clutter my
children go through all of their toys
and we wash them we clean them we put
them in cute little bags and then we
donate them to centers around our
community and they love acting like
Santa and sharing their toys and stuff
and it gives us kind of that
pre-Christmas Purge period
also we
have we live in an RV full-time and so
having that limit to the space has
definitely helped us with the
grandparents and that kind of stuff with
they give us more experiences than stuff
since I know we just physically don't
have room all right that's our minimal
episode for today we'll see you on
patreon for the full two hour maximal
edition of episode 381 which includes
answers to a bunch more questions for
Catherine and the minimalists also a new
obsolete objects segment involving a
seven thousand dollar storage locker an
outstanding added value segment here's a
hint I bought 24 of them
minimalist
and we got much much more of less and if
you want to hear all that check out the
minimalist private podcast at
patreon.com the minimalist or click the
link in the description to subscribe and
get your personal link so that our
weekly maximal episodes play in your
favorite podcast app you'll also gain
access to all of our podcast archives
all the way back the episode zero zero
one and if you're still on the fence
here's a testimonial from one of our
lovely patreon supporters Patrick says
hi new Patron from Croatia here after 10
years of following you on all platforms
it's a bit excessive
I finally pulled the plug and became a
private podcast listener today after
hearing just one private episode I can
say that this is one of the best
decisions I've ever made wow Patrick
we're gonna have to send you an invoice
for the last 10 years
[Laughter]
no we really appreciate your support
thank you so much for joining uh the
private podcast and I will tell you this
if you're listening to this and you're
on the fence try it out for a month what
you'll get there is a deep dive not just
into letting go of your stuff but mental
clutter relationship clutter
psychological clutter is what we talked
about a lot today so many other forms of
clutter that manifest in our lives in
developing a better understanding of
those our private podcast is the place
where Ryan and TK and Mallory and I have
the opportunity to talk about things
that we don't typically talk about in
public and we do so in these long-form
conversations with all of these
different segments and we address some
things that well they need to be
addressed
big thanks to Catherine Morgan schaffler
for joining us today you can check out
her brand new book it's called the
perfectionist's guide to losing control
we'll put a link to that in the show
notes over at about minimalistics.com
podcast you can also find her website
and her Instagram if you'd like to
follow along as well and if you leave
here today with just one message please
let it be this
love people and use things
because the opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time peace
every little thing
every little thing little thing you
think that you need every little thing
that's just feeding your greed or I bet
that you'll be fine without it